fighting with my family is written and
directed by Stephen Merchant and tells
the story of Paige WWE wrestler her
unusual family and how they fought in a
very different way how her love of
wrestling began the relationship that
she shares with her brother how both of
them really wanted to be wrestlers and
how hard that actually is for them once
they get their shot this movie actually
really surprised me I got really into
the film the story made me feel
something I actually felt I I cared
about what was happening I gave a shit
you know and it wasn't just because it
was a heartwarming film that's obviously
crowd-pleasing because it's definitely
going for those fields and it really
wants you to stand up and Cheer and get
all those critic quotes that say you're
gonna clap even though you probably
won't much of it is due to Stephen
merchants writing the dialogue here is
really really fresh and the family
dynamic is so so funny Nick Frost is
goddamn hilarious in this movie
especially in an early scene where he's
talking to another wrestler and he's
trying to figure out just how much he
will take in the ring how much abuse can
this wrestler take would he take it hit
to the face with garbage can well let's
find out
it's a great scene I was eating popcorn
while watching it and I kind of choked
on the popcorn because I was laughing so
hard there's a lot of scenes like that
early on mostly due to Nick Frost that
are gut-busting Lee hilarious also very
funny Vince Vaughn as the coach for NXT
when she is training and trying to
figure out if she could become a WWE
wrestler his insults are so on point it
kind of reminded me of hacksaw Ridge in
which he played a similar character just
a little more toned down less profanity
this time but I felt the real heart and
soul of this movie was the relationship
between Paige and her brother because
both of them are very much so in this
like they really want it and when things
don't go a hundred percent according to
plan it causes a lot of family drama and
that's where the movie really got under
my skin in a good way like it actually
made me feel a lot for this family and
yeah sometimes it goes in a familiar
direction some of the scenes can be you
know derivative of other movies that
we've seen a thousand times there's only
so many ways you can tell an inspiring
story about someone who wants to be a
wrestler or a boxer or a basketball star
or football
star and this movie does follow that
same path and that's fine honestly I've
said this a billion times in my reviews
I don't care if a movie has cliches if
it does them well that's great good you
did it
you made me feel something good job
despite being prominently featured on
the poster the rock does not have a huge
role in this movie as I'm sure most of
you probably know he's in the movie
every once in a while as true to the
real-life story with Paige he was
integral to getting her to get into the
ring and some involvement there the
movie glosses over some facts and some
things have to be changed to make the
movie more interesting you know because
if you knew things ahead of time it just
wouldn't be as fun which I get you need
that but if you really want to know the
true tale behind it there's tons of
documentaries and you know featurettes
about Paige and the things that she went
through it's a very inspiring story and
the movie is also very inspiring I would
say Stephen merchant's a better writer
than he is a director not that the
film's poorly directed it's just that
the writing was so good the direction
kind of disappears sometimes it feels a
little bit listless not in a bad way I
must say I'm kind of reaching for things
at this point but like it you can just
tell that his writing is a lot stronger
than his visual intuitiveness which is
the most pretentious way I can say that
the movie didn't look as good as the
stuff they were saying and towards the
end if you know the real life story it
doesn't feel quite as hard-hitting as it
could be in the emotional gut you know
some things are going to happen and some
of it does feel a bit rushed
towards the end there but overall this
was a pretty inspiring movie and filled
with great performances very very funny
extremely well-written I would recommend
checking it out I'm gonna get fighting
with my family a b-plus guys thank you
so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon I got
some more coming to you this weekend as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]